now we're going to spend some time
building cat clicker together with
knockout you can find the files i'm
using at the repository linked in the
instructor notes now here's our index
HTML file but we're going to put that
aside and open up a pas as you can see
we're starting with absolutely nothing
here first let's make a view model so we
have a place to put things now if we
only type this nothing special will
happen we'll just end up with a function
called view model but it won't ever get
run we need to tell knockout to apply
our bindings to this view model now I'll
go over what that means in more detail a
little bit later for now let's just
start our app by typing KO to apply
bindings and a new view model now let's
hop over to our browser hit refresh and
ensure that nothing pops up in the
console when i'm developing i go back
and forth a lot to make sure I don't run
into errors now let's go back to our app
we need to put something inside our view
model here for now I'm actually going to
put our model here in the view model now
this may seem confusing at first you may
think but Ben aren't we supposed two
separate things well the most important
thing for now is that the pieces are
functionally separate for simplicity in
this example we'll define our model
stuff here inside the view model but
even though the model is being defined
inside the view model the functionality
is separate now in a few lessons will
see a good way to separate out our model
data more cleanly but for now we'll go
with this so what do we need in here
well we need the same fields as before
name click count image source and
because we appreciate our artists image
attribution and there's our model for a
simple version of cat clicker now what
about our view model we obviously need
an increment counter function but if we
look back at our previous code from the
last lesson you'll notice we don't need
most of the functions we wrote before
for example before we had a get current
cat function which allowed the view to
get it from the octopus to get it from
the model we don't need that anymore
because knockout will handle the view to
model and ma
to view synchronization for us the only
time we need to write viewmodel methods
are when we need to actually change
something ourselves in this case this
increment counter is going to set the
cliq count to be itself plus one as you
can see this click count with nothing in
the method is getting our click count
we're adding one and then taking this
whole thing here and storing it inside
of this that click out effectively what
we've done here is say count + + in this
case it's this click count and this that
click count is a knockout observable now
all we need to do is make our HTML
connect up with this